كاظم الساهر يطلق اغنيه اوقف نيرانك هند
صبري ومنى زكي تسجلان موقفا من منظمات
انسانيه مهرجان ضيافه واعلان عن بطوله
للكلاب في موسم الرياض يشعل مواقع التواصل
اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع اطلق المطرب العراقي كاظم الساهر
اغنيه فاير بالتعاون مع جمعيه الامم
المتحده للموسيقى الكلاسيكيه لدعم السلام
والجهود الانسانيه وتسليط الضوء على العمل
الانساني الاغنيه من كلمات توم لو والحان
كاظم وتوزيع ميشيل فاضل وسيتم التبرع
بعائدات لدعم انشطه الامم المتحده
الانسانيه وكاله الامم المتحده لاغاثه
وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين ومناطق
النزاع في الشرق الاوسط احنا
نحبكم اخواننا في غزه قلوبنا معكم احنا
معكم
بالمقابل اعلنت الفنانه التونسيه هند صبري
استقالتها من برنامج الغذاء العالمي
التابع للامم المتحده بعد 13 عاما على
انضمامها للبرنامج كسفي للنوايا الحسنه
بسبب ما وصفته بالعجز عن منع استخدام
التجويع والحصار كاسل الحه حرب في غزه
واتى اعلان صبري في بيان نشرته عبر
حساباتها الرسميه على منصات التواصل وتلقت
سي ان ام بالعربيه نسخه
منه
[موسيقى]
ومن دبي عبرت النجمه المصريه منى زكي عن
تضامنها بوضوح مع الضحايا الفلسطينيين في
غزه خلال تكريمها في مهرجان ضيافه وذلك في
كلمه لافته القتها بمناسبه تكريمها سجلت
فيها موقفا من المنظمات الانسانيه انت
بتتولد بيها وبتبقى جواك وبتبقى عارف ايه
الرولز بتاعتها من غير ما يبقى فيش تحطلك
يعني ايه انك تبقى انسان وكانت غزه حاضره
في كلمات العديد من النجوم العرب الذين
كرمهم المهرجان هذا العام وكان مفاجاته
المغني المغربي سعد
المجرد بلاك
مهم وحل واش بقي فرح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فييوم ومن دبي الى العاصمه السعوديه
والتفاعل الواسع مع حفل الفنان المصري
محمد رمضان في موسم الرياض كما حقق اعلان
الموسم عن موعد اول مهرجان في العالم يجمع
اربع بطولات الكلاب في مكان واحد ضجه على
مواقع التواصل وشهد موسم الرياضه الاسبوع
الماضي افتتاح متحف سي ار س الذي يسلط
الضوء على انجازات رونالدو في كره القدم
وارقامه
العالميه ونختتم الابرز بخبر الرحيل
الصادم للفنان المصري طارق عبد العزيز عن
عمر 55 عاما حيث فارق الراحل الحياه جراء
تعرضه لازمه قلبيه بينما كان يصور دوره في
عمل فني سلام عم نور
[موسيقى]
يلا